- I DO.
IT'S MONDAY.
- INITIATION DAY!
TONIGHT, YOU PLEDGES
BECOME MEMBERS
OF KAPPA ZETA NU.
WHICH MEANS
WE GOTTA DRINK THE HOUSE DRY.
RIGHT NOW!
- LET'S DO IT.
- OH, MAN.
COME ON,
I'M TOO SLEEPY THOUGH.
- YEAH, WE'RE INTO IT.
WE JUST--WE NEED A LITTLE BREAK.
- OH, I'M SORRY.
ARE YOU GUYS ON YOUR PERIODS?
all: NO.
- WELL, THAT'S TOO BAD,
'CAUSE I AM.
- OH!
- WHOA!
- UGH!
- VERY GROSS.
- VODKA-SOAKED TAMPON.
ALCOHOL ABSORBS,
LIKE, 50 TIMES FASTER
THROUGH THE POOPER.
- THAT'S COOL.
- IT'S SCIENCE!
- IT'S GROSS, MAN!
AND DANGEROUS, FOR SURE.
- DON'T BE GAY.
PUT THIS IN YOUR BUTT.
- NO.
- YOU PUT THIS
IN YOUR SOUTH MOUTH RIGHT NOW,
OR NO KAPPA ZETA NU!
- I'M NOT PUTTING ANYTHING
UP MY BUTT.
THAT IS A PRIVILEGED AREA
FOR MY FIRST WIFE ONLY,
IF SHE SO WANTS
TO EXPLORE THERE.
- AIN'T A DAMN THING
CHANGED.
- I'LL DO IT.
IT'LL BE AN HONOR.
- YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
- JUST SHOVE IT
RIGHT UP THERE, HUH?
EW.
- GOOD DECISION.
YOU [bleep] BITCH!
- [laughing]
YEAH!
- IT'S TOO LATE.
- I'M A BITCH!
WHOO!
- LATER, BOYS!
KAPPA ZETA NU ONLY.
- WHOO!
I'M PART OF THE ZOO!
[mimicking monkey]
[barking]
IT'S LIKE A MONKEY-DOG.
- STICK THAT UP YOUR ASS NOW,
YOU PUSSY!
- YES, SIR.
OH! WOW!
OH! HO!
OH, MY GOD, IT'S LIKE
MY BUTTHOLE GRABBED IT.
THAT WAS EASY!
IT JUST--